[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'iphone vite on l'appelle aussi
l'iphone x x pourquoi pour les dix ans
de la seule l'iphone os x ou l'iphone 10
comme tu veux ça fait dix ans en 2007
que apple lancer son tout premier
smartphone qui a révolutionné le monde
de la téléphonie est attaqué la manne
powell milliard et là il envisage de
lancer le nouveau téléphone l'iphone 8
en tout cas ce sera le huitième numéro
avec plein de fonctionnalités et ce
téléphone est hyper intéressant pourquoi
parce qu'il va avoir plein de nouveautés
hyper passionnante on va commencer
vraiment à sentir une évolution
alléluia jusque là on avait notre bon
vieux iphone moi j'ai l'iphone si c'est
ce qui me sert d'ailleurs a enregistré
voilà ça c'est mon iphone 6 s j'ai eu
avant 1,4 en iphone 4 j'ai eu un gym je
sais plus le 3g je crois je suis un vrai
fan d'apple un les ipad jamais tu vois
ça d'un ipad
j'ai un macbook pro qui me servent à
faire mon montage qui est europe via la
toile justement voilà macbook pro une
watch je suis un super grand fan d'apple
parce que je trouve qu'ils ont vraiment
réussi à créer une marque forte avec une
identité et une cohérence entre tous les
produits chaque produit à sa place
certains se superposent en termes de
fonctionnalités et tous les produits
sont complémentaires que ce soit la
ouache qui va être complémentaire avec
l'iphone la watch à son sens l'iphone
elle a très peu d'intérêt tous les
produits sont cohérents il ya vraiment
un système apple est une grande
cohérence entre tous les produits et je
trouve ça juste extraordinaire et le
nouvel iphone qui va sortir en septembre
normalement septembre 2017
il va avoir plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités alors pour l'instant ce
sont des rumeurs mais vous savez bien
que les rumeurs aux règles générales
elle se base sur des réalités sur des
vérités et justement ces rumeurs je vais
énumérer
on devrait normalement avoir un iphone
avec un plus grand écran l'écran devrait
en tout cas occupé toute la longueur il
devrait même être légèrement incurvé
comme sur les samsung
parce que en réalité
elle a négocié avec samsung contrats
juteux très vite pour samsung
parce que vous savez que samsung est
quand même le numéro un au niveau des
écrans ils ont négocié un contrat quand
j'étais sa dé 4,3 milliards de dollars
pour l'achat d'écrans donc samsung va
fournir apple au niveau de ces nouveaux
écrans des écrans qui normalement
devrait être incurvé des écrans oled de
5 2 8 pouces donc on devrait avoir un
superbe écran tout en sachant que ce
sera effectivement un écran bord à bord
on va pas se retrouver avec comme si on
les produits actuels avec des petits
bords ce sera vraiment un bord à bord
est normalement légèrement incurvé ça
c'est pour l'écran est la grande
nouveauté il faut savoir que sur l'écran
aussi le bouton home que vous avez là
devraient disparaître
on devrait se retrouver avec un écran on
espère en tout cas sur toute la longueur
du téléphone quelque chose comme ça
c'est pas sûr mais en tout cas voilà ça
très ressemble un petit peu ça le bouton
home devrait disparaître et on devrait
pouvoir débloquer son téléphone de
n'importe quel endroit soit directement
avec son pouce soit avec un nouveau
système de reconnaissance faciale
bien que vous serez face à son téléphone
comme ça par la caméra il reconnaîtrait
votre visage et là il est des engrais
directement au téléphone ce qui fait
plus besoin de taper le code fastidieux
à lui à 6 chiffres
maintenant plus besoin d'aller appuyez
vous placez votre téléphone face à vous
il est en mode veille d' y reconnaît aux
deux visages
ils se débrouillent automatiquement ça
c'est juste génial et c'est un vrai gain
de temps après il y aussi les
spéculations qui disent qu'il pourrait
faire d'un scanner d'iris c'est par
lettre est effectivement de
déverrouiller assez rapidement pour ce
qu'ils ne savent pas iris c'est dans
l'oeil tu vas trucs comme dans les
séries un petit peu futuriste dans les
films futuristes
oui tuscan tournefeuille le principe
serait le même tu te placerait comme ça
et deux cadres est bon je crois plus
facilement à la reconnaissance
faciale tôt qu'au scanner d'iris mais
après pourquoi pas effectivement ça il
faut affiner toujours est il qu'il y
aura une reconnaissance visuelle qui
sera faite de par téléphone l'iris ou la
forme du visage ça on sait pas encore
c'est un produit qui normalement devrait
sortir en septembre 2007 et qui va
commencer et qui va rentrer à
fabrication un petit peu plus tôt que
ses prédécesseurs normalement apple
lancer sa fabrication à 12 juillet
précédent effectivement là le lancement
deux mois avant là normalement ils vont
commencer au mois de juin donc on se
demande si c'est effectivement pour
pallier à la demande
ce comme ça va être un produit un
produit qui va porter plainte nouveauté
ils s'attendent probablement à une
révolution et a beaucoup de ventes donc
ça peut être ça peut effectivement être
la raison première la deuxième raison
c'est effectivement à ce moment là un
une fabrication qui sera un peu plus
lente ce qui est aussi possible
est-ce que la fabrication prendra plus
de temps et c'est pour ça qu'ils le
mettent en application plus tôt voilà ça
on sait pas encore exactement toujours
est il que normalement ce téléphone
selon les fuites sera en sera mis en
fabrication
en juin de cette année autre grande
nouveauté c'est un téléphone qui ne se
rechargera pas qu'on avait l'habitude
directement avec une prise dessus il y
aura plus du tout prise ici et c'est un
téléphone que vous allez rechargées par
induction vous allez être posé sur une
plaque et il va recharger
on devrait avoir normalement 5 en
autonomie pour cinq heures de charge
ça serait vraiment pas mal alors le
principe de l'adduction si vous ne
connaissez pas ces deux mêmes principes
que la cuisson par induction
c'est à dire que vous allez poser votre
téléphone directement dessus il va y
avoir un système d'aimants qui va
reconnaître qui va déclencher
l'induction
normalement ça devrait chauffer un peu
plus donc ils ont rajouté des composants
qui vont isoler et qu'il devrait faire
que le téléphone sera un peu plus cher
mais ça on reparle dans quelques
instants
d'ailleurs le système d'adduction je
sais pas si vous savez mais on retrouve
déjà sur la watch clair pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de voix dix d'apple
il n'y a absolument rien pour brancher
la montre tu peux le voir et le chargeur
c'est ça voilà
on reconnaît l'autre bout d'al usb c'est
un grand classique chez apple et en fin
de compte ce que tu fais c'est que tu
vas le poser non sans l'autre ils sont
aimantés tu vois le fait que ce soit ils
mentent et c'est ça qui va déclencher
induction et c'est ça qui va déclencher
la charge
donc voilà ça c'est le système tout en
sachant que les systèmes d'adduction
tuner trouve déjà sur plein de téléphone
portable mais que pour l'instant apple
n'a toujours pas franchi le pas donc ça
devrait être la grande nouveauté sur
cette édition est sûre cette mouture là
ça c'est juste extraordinaire d'autant
plus qu'il ya plein de voitures
je pense notamment aux séries aux
voitures premium au dernière bmw où il
ya une partie ou toute l'opposition
téléphone et le recharger par induction
ça tu peux le faire avec samsung mais
toujours est il qu'avec un iphone
aujourd'hui c'est pas recommandé donc on
ne peut en théorie pas le faire je te
parle du prix je te disais qu
effectivement le prix elle être un peu
plus élevé parce qu'ils ont dû rajouter
une petite couche d'isolant par rapport
effectivement au fait que la recharge à
induction va chauffer davantage ça
forcément ça doit augmenter le prix est
ce un téléphone qui va être encore un
peu plus cher normalement selon les
rumeurs c'est un téléphone qu'on devrait
trouver aux alentours de 1000 $ à sa
sortie il devrait même être peut-être
aux alentours de 1200 euros en europe
donc forcément tu vois il sera quand
même plus cher que l'iphone 5
après il faut voir peut-être qui aura
des options sur certains et pas sur
d'autres qui vont permettre une certaine
variabilité des tarifs toujours est il
qu'on avance voire 1000 $ pour la sortie
de l'iphone 8
côté technique aussi normalement le
châssis alu du l'iphone devrait être
remplacé par un châssis en acier et on
devrait avoir une couche de verre sur le
dessus et une couche de verre sur le
dessous et du coup ça ça rappellera
vraiment un peu le principe de l'iphone
cap lizard normalement un téléphone qui
va être encore plus résistant à l'eau
que l'iphone 7 est encore plus résistant
la poussière parce qu'il devrait avoir
la certification ip68 il faut savoir
actuellement l'iphone cette nac la
certification ip67 ce qui veut dire
qu'on téléphone tu peux effectivement le
mouillé mais que par contre apple ne
garantit pas du tout une étanchéité à
100%
même si tu nous lis légèrement
normalement avec une certification ip68
doit être le cas tu dois pouvoir immergé
pendant une demi-heure dans un mètre
cinquante de profondeur
bon ça c'est la grand
et oui parce qu'en réalité ça doit être
uniquement de l'eau douce studio 12 10
t'oublies la mer t'oublies océans dès
qu'il va y avoir l'eau salée ces morts
tous qu'il va être piscine les
traitements clore ces morts les
traitements hausse elle aussi dans les
piscines ces morts et dès qu'il y a un
peu trop de pression d'eau sous une
chute d'eau des choses comme ça pareil
c'est mort donc lhi p 68 ans a été c'est
bien si ton téléphone tu le mouiller un
peu où tu les chats pendant la vaisselle
sinon tu ne peux rien faire d'autre
en tout cas c'est déconseillé et si
toutefois tu te retrouves à le faire
tomber dans la mer et que ton téléphone
prenez la flotte et que tu l'envoyant en
garantie chez apple
ce n'est même pas sûr qu'ils acceptent
de le changer
comme je le disais le bouton home qui
est en bas ici devrait disparaître et tu
devrais te retrouver soi avec une petite
molette comme sur la watch la rumeur dit
qu'il y aura peut-être une molette qui
permettra d'avoir un scroll plus facile
d'avoir un zoom plus facile ou de
pouvoir contrôler le volume sonore assez
facilement donc normalement déjà que les
deux boutons là ça va relativement bien
alors fait une mode intégré un tu vois
pas forcément une molette être approuvé
au milieu comme comme une grosse verrue
sur un visage dégueulasse une petite
molette probablement sur le côté ce qui
en soi n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
idée mais l'idée qui à mon avis la plus
judicieuse
c'est la touch barque comme tu trouves
sur les nouveaux macbook pro tu devrais
pouvoir la retrouver en bas tu l'as vue
sur la démo un jeu passe tu as fais
gaffe sur les pubs apple qui vend une
petite taille de bar sur le macbook pro
pour faire des montages vidéo notamment
tu peux le bouger plus facilement donc
ça doit pouvoir être une option qui à
mon avis sera la plus judicieuse et qui
devrait apporter plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités on parle aussi d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle pour pouvoir
intégrer ton iphone 8 directement comme
les casques samsung tu pourras voir la
vr qui pourrait aussi rejoindre la
réalité augmentée pu voir pas mal de
choses et pourquoi pas des hologrammes
directement on peut imaginer des
conversations téléphoniques on peut
imaginer plein de choses comme ça ça se
passe à regarder mais sans le casque
oculus de facebook qui le présentait ils
avaient leurs avatars qui pouvaient
superposer à la réalité ce qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs la réalité augmentée imagine
que tu me balade chez toi ou tu sois
bureau avec ton casque et que tu vois la
bâtarde la personne pourquoi pas
carrément la personne en face de toi en
train de téléphoner par l'être encore
plus de cons
via lité et d'avoir des solutions qui
seraient beaucoup plus sympa et ça c'est
vraiment un argument qui a fait mouche
parce qu'il ya quelques mois au moment
où j'ai commandé mon iphone 6 s je vais
poser la question de vaches poulets chez
samsung
à contrecoeur et parce que vraiment
entre systèmes de casques de réalité
virtuelle
c'est quelque chose qui me séduisait
énormément autre grande nouveauté syrie
devrait vraiment évoluer et faire encore
un pas de plus vers l'intelligence
artificielle on devrait avoir une série
qui serait capable de comprendre
probablement d'apprendre et d'évoluer et
ça c'est vraiment l'avenir de
l'intelligence artificielle et c'est
même le but de l'intelligence
artificielle c'est l'iran une place de
choix au coeur du nouvel iphone 8
de toute façon apple ne peut pas se
planter que le nouvel iphone parce que
en 2016
les ventes d'iphone représenter à peu
près 70 % du chiffre d'affaires d'apple
c'est juste énorme
donc là c'est un très gros challenge à
relever d'autant plus que samsung va
lancer son galaxy sii très prochainement
le concurrent direct il faut savoir qu'à
quelques années quand samsung s'est
lancé sur le marché de la téléphonie
mobile
ils ont vraiment compté il ya eu une
guerre des brevets c'est facile si tu
t'en souviens d'ailleurs c'est à dire à
l'époque il y avait vraiment une guerre
des brevets entre apple et samsung
samsung pompe est réellement apple sauf
que depuis samsung a créé son propre
chemin a eu ses propres brevets est on
vraiment lancer des innovations
technologiques pour la téléphonie mobile
il était hyper fort sur les écrans sont
toujours hyper croix sur les écrans
d'ailleurs on peut le voir parce
qu'apple va acheter les écrans
maintenant directement à samsung pour
son nouvel iphone mais samsung va
trouver sa propre voie
donc aujourd'hui on a deux concurrents
sérieux apple d'un côté samsung de
l'autre la guerre est lancée et je pense
que vraiment l'un et l'autre vont se
tirer vers le haut ils vont apporter de
nouvelles fonctionnalités et crée
nouveaux besoins
voilà aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire un
peu sur ce nouvel iphone je pense que
pour les dix ans apple va sortir plein
d'autres surprises qu'on va se régaler
qu'on va avoir au mois septembre un
nouvel iphone flambant neuf et qui va
vraiment rendre tous les autres or en
plus obsolète pour l'instant j'aime en 6
s j'attends avec impatience de voir ce
que apple va vraiment nous réserver
voilà ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui sur
un petit peu les nouveautés et sur les
différentes rumeurs courent sur iphone
je pense que par contre voilà ça va être
super produit et je pense qu'on va se
régaler dis moi ce que t'en penses foire
par contre dit moi je sais pas c'était
sale phong cité apple tu peux aussi des
plats note martin il ya sony qui existe
il ya htc qui a encore assez fortement
le marché qu'elle et toi tu ta marque de
téléphone fétiche
est ce que tu es pro apple il ya des
gens qui détestent carrément apple parce
qu'effectivement ils ont une amie sur un
marché et ils ont un culte de la marque
qui est énorme
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait tout
l'intérêt c'est pour ça que les
passionnés adorent temps cette marque
parce qu'il ya vraiment ce culte de la
marque est extrêmement fort dis moi ce
que t'en penses
dis moi c'est un apple dis moi si tu
compte acheter l'iphone 8 quelles
fonctionnalités tu attendrait pas de
nouveaux téléphones pour basculer est
allé sur de l'achat et si cette vidéo
plus abonne toi n'hésite pas à regarder
celle là elle est aussi très sympa et
pour ta bonne et c'est dans la diagonale
en vain je te remercie je te dis à très
vite
à bientôt fond de vallée réduite shout